hello internet we are going to watch
today from
film theory the giant monster hiding
in the in shang to shane teacher that's
a repeats it
you know we love phil there's we're
going to watch this you know how we do
shang chi was a great
wow that shangshi trailer looks really
cool
after conquering almost every other
action machine
get it right martial arts what a great
idea
why they didn't
hey louis tan wire work and dojos
so weird that they have never once tried
to do this before
yup very first time
hey man daredevil like great action even
though it's not the same kind of
fantastical element
it's great hello internet welcome to
film
theory the show that wants to challenge
your smash style against our fist of the
subscribe button uh that's my overly
elaborate way of saying subscribe to
this channel you know marvel's upcoming
shang chi
or as mcu big wig kevin feige puts it
shang shi in the legend the ten rings
so shang shi is the pronunciation i'm
going to be rolling with today chongqing
the legend of the ten rings is a lot
more than just the mcu's sincere apology
for the existence of iron fist
i thought the iron fist was a great
warrior
you fight like a child finding a tantrum
review of that show in a nutshell
it's also the first mcu here taking so
much time to bang on
two and a half years ago and before that
it was black panther three years ago
just saying it has been a
long time since we've seen some new
faces in this franchise
it'll also be big mickey's the latest
shot at getting a foothold into
ever-expanding chinese box office while
also also serving as a much needed
that's a sachi subject right now
this universe so yeah a lot is gonna be
riding on this one but in addition
to all that other stuff the reason i'm
talking about it here today on the
channel is that it's also
a big mystery you see shongxi is a
fairly obscure character whose backstory
front story and really his entire thing
absolutely needed a full rebuild for
this movie released in the more
culturally sensitive times of 2021.
especially culturally sensitive time
since already having cultural sensitive
issues over in china right now might not
get released
for not being culturally appropriate
enough yeah
they can't win with song chi man isn't
it gonna happen
and considering that disney has
everything locked down tighter than
scrooge mcduck's bitcoin password we
don't know
anything about the actual crypto invest
or
do we that's right internet theory
master matpat is skipping your
instruction
all the way ahead to the 36th chamber
and cracking the biggest secrets of the
first
mcu kung fu movie today i'm here to
predict shangshi
four months before it's actually
released what it's probably about who
these people are
why it's really called the ten rings
where those rings actually come from
and how i predict marvel has a giant
kaiju size
surprise waiting in the wings at the end
of all that kicking
get ready to eat your heart out and
considering the winning streak we've
been on lately when it comes to marvel
theories i'm putting the spoiler warning
right now first things first who is
shangshi well in the 1970s chinese kung
fu films exploded into a big pop culture
fad thanks in part to two converging
forces the first was the absolute
magazine
the second was independent movie
theaters opting the screen trucking
master
because they were relatively cheap i
haven't seen 36 chambers
as excited the young hip audience for
the genre and marvel comics working
under the motto of we also enjoy money
wanted their own martial arts themed
superhero they started by trying to get
the rights to kung fu
a tv series that was airing at the time
but warner brothers said no they had to
make up their own guy
and the shi was born he's a chinese
master of innumerable hand-to-hand
fighting and weapon styles
so skilled that his abilities border on
the supernatural but as far as marvel
heroes go he's
he's actually pretty normal he's a kung
fu guy and he mostly does kung fu
things so what's he going to be doing in
this movie well according to toy leaks
yes toy leaks we can get a good sense of
what's actually going to be going on
here the plumber
you might expect involved the crime
syndicate and terrorist organization the
ten rings a lot of things get leaked to
toys background since the first iron man
they speak arabic urdu
mongolian parsi russian the irish people
they call themselves and the dragon is
in the billboard
razer fist what was shong shi's sister
jai ling with whom his relationship is
uh
complicated to say the least but the
real big thing here and the reason fans
who know their comics lord did about
five spit takes
the ten rings part of the title is that
chongxie has himself some major daddy
issues
like most of the superheroes in there
absolutely and in this version that
daddy's name is gonna be
the man did you know that fortune
cookies
aren't even chinese they're made by
americans based on
based on a japanese recipe hey bloody
hell bloody hell
no not him but also yes kind to him now
the mandarin is a long beloved bad guy
to a few generations of marvel comic
fans he was basically iron man's
on-again-off-again main nemesis in the
comics for a lot of the 60s 70s and 80s
but his cultural awareness has evolved
over time he's become
increasingly problematic there's just no
getting around the fact that he mainly
came into being as a pretty iffy chinese
villain stereotype during the era when
iron man was marvel's de facto
anti-communist superhero most of his
enemies were just stand-ins for either
soviet or chinese communist threats
very very stereotypical stand-ins that's
why the various iron man adaptations
over the years have tried to find ways
to work around the problematic parts of
the character while still
getting him in there somehow in some
form the 90s iron man cartoon gave him
green skin and downplayed the
exaggerated orientalism of his
i just love how they keep they're trying
so hard i'm watching this progression
and iron man 3 infamously reimagined the
character even more radically as a
globalized amalgam of hyped-up foreign
threats to the u.s definitely not
marketing illusion my name is trevor
trevor slattery
what are you i'm an actor just a role
the mandarin see it's not real and the
real mandarin was um
well he was an evil weapons tycoon who
also had fire powers who's always me
tony
right from the start justice for
aldridge killing one
weird call on multiple levels some
people love that i think you just gotta
make him a stereotypical asian guy
go the opposite direction make him more
stereotypical cast like
nicholas cage to be the mandarin
all right look we're not gonna satisfy
anyone
you might as well stick to your comic's
origins
make it as racist as possible yeah this
is historical fiction and and we got to
represent the accurate history
i hate when they change things from the
comics
culture's ruining my my racism woke
culture which has only existed for about
five years now has really been wrecking
these comics for the last 30 to 40 years
no that's uh they're tall jokes although
i would love to see someone
actually attempted and and then get a
lot of hate
it would be hilarious to me it's like a
fan film or something we're doing the
true man
i am the amanda rand like is that some
guy comes out it's the most
stereotypical
and it's a white guy i have 10 rings
yeah she's like a clear white too
just doing those stereotypical [ __ ]
this is this makes me laugh thinks that
someone would attempt it some people
loved the twist but others really didn't
and so marvel split the difference with
a follow-up that i predict not many of
you
not even the hardest of hardcore
marvelites have watched
marvel one shot all hail the king a
twenty
i love that one short film released
direct to video as a part justin hammers
in the two dark world oh that's it that
that's why no one saw this thing
oh it's the fan base kiss my rings
the short film is indeed short it's only
ten minutes but it has some really
awesome one-liners
you're not capable of pulling that
trigger mr slattery i'm an out-of-work
actor love
you've no idea what i'm capable of and
thanks to the cbs network i'm pretty
good with a handgun as well as a special
appearance from everyone's favorite arms
dealer justin hammer
tony and i tony tony and tony's cool
both brothers in arms you know
literally we're both arms dealers but
the big twist is that it ends with an
ominous cliffhanger implying a real
mandarin actually has existed this
entire time
you took his name and now he wants it
back
no sorry i still don't get it and after
seven long years
that mandarin seems to finally be making
his appearance in shanghai it's been
seven years
damn the connection back to this new
movie remember how marvel thought that
they needed to feel like a lifetime
against
martial arts comic but when they
couldn't get that they instead chose to
license the publishing rights to a
famous chinese villain character
and then they wrote chongshi's origins
good guy son the character the fiendish
dr
fu manchu not much better than the
mandarin the recurring bad guys
adventure novel nicholas cage
in all of fiction a super intelligent
criminal mastermind who dabbled in the
occult and mad science with designs of
taking over the world
just an absurd amount of the super
villain tropes that we now take for
granted in terms of secret layers evil
plots henchmen booby traps mad
science labs torture chambers all of it
either originated or were largely
popularized by this one guy
he was also an absurdly gross anti-asian
stereotype
as you can obviously tell either way
marvel lost away
so she's terrible she needed to be less
racist about their multiple evil chinese
science wizard characters so now all of
these events are coming together so that
when woo
the true mandarin is filling the role of
shang xi's dad so ultimately the plot of
this thing is good guy
shangshi rebelling against evil crime
lord winner dad which brings us then to
the 10 rings themselves now in the
comics the mandarin has historically
worn 10 rings of power that each grant a
different super ability
ice fire electricity vortex aka wind
white light black lights which you never
want to use in a motel room psychic
impact beam disintegration and matter
rearranger pretty much the infinity
gauntlet again but with some extra
captain planity powers mixed in because
you know now there's a whole other hand
they have to fill up but in the trailer
appear to be rings rather they appear to
be metal bands worn around the villains
they're still rings they're ring shaped
showing off the rings wrapped around
each of his forearms now
that is a pretty big change but it's one
that comes with a few logical
explanations
chongxie is a martial arts film grounded
in the tradition of chinese kung fu
and iron ring style is a thing in both
the folklore and
reality of chinese martial arts southern
shaolin masters who practice rooted
stances like horse style and the famous
hungar technique are known to use
traditional training methods where heavy
iron rings are worn on the arms for
strength and muscle building and to
master the movement of physical force
through the moving and stopping of limbs
you know earth benders like tough and
evident
very much tied to traditional hangar
technique and chinese kung fu movies
have often depicted southern xiaolin
and hungar associated folk heroes using
combat versions of the rings as actual
weapons in battle does police story
[Music]
live action movie mandarin's 10 rings
being adapted into something more like
hungar fighting rings that's cool
does raise the question if they're on
his arms and not his fingers don't they
stop being rings and become the ten
bracelets and sure anytime like that
could easily be a tension breaking quip
a marvel character could drop in the
middle of a fight or
here's my big prediction for this one
friends they're still rings but they're
not
rings made for human fingers what if
they happen to be rings that were once
worn
oh there you go yeah like like the
origin
hear me out here guys what something
else the mcu hasn't gone and fully given
us yet
a giant monster character sure there
have been a few
giants here and there the frost giants
most notably certain
at the end of thor ragnarok i mean let's
slow down for a second i love
the idea of incorporating like the
bracelets by
giving it to that traditional kung fu
shaolin fighting aesthetic that we've
seen in several movies over the years
it's been a part of culture as well
so i think that's a neat way to do it
because i think rings can be really
goofy and cheesy especially when they're
going for more of like
a grounded take i don't know if the
right word's grounded but you know not
it's more grounded in tradition
yeah yeah exactly and they really want
this to feel like it
like an asian kung fu film and so i
think going down that path
is really cool but yeah i mean like in a
version of the comics uh when he does
get the rings they are
uh uh connected to fing pang fum already
right so and
there are a lot of rumors have been
going around the finger fang foo
might appear in this movie i don't see
how that would be possible
but overall a shocking lap of big
oversized creatures for these god-like
characters to fight and while the other
marvel martial arts thing did a bunch of
big talk about a dragon they apparently
couldn't afford to show it ever
but chongshi has both money and an
excuse to have a giant dragon
yeah not just because the only thing
that you'll find more of in chinese
folklore than martial arts masters is
dragons you see there's a dragonish
candidate sitting in the marvel comics
canon who's tangled with shongxi before
and would fit the bill
perfectly and his name is fin fangfun
you can't bury this stuff up obviously
it can someone clearly did at some point
in history but
that's what we're going with originally
created as part of marvel's
pre-superhero crazy stuff from space
stories finn fang fume is a sort of
humanoid-shaped dragon who's actually an
alien visitor named
mac luon originating in the 60s and
revived by marvel writers in the 70s
pretty much for the sole reason that his
name is fun to say finn fang fu
has been all over the place so he's a
dragon kinda so what well what makes him
a perfect fit to show up here
in this movie in this specific context
is that the comics origin of the
mandarin's rings
usually frame them as not being magical
or supernatural
but rather advanced alien technology
that the man who'd later become the
mandarin found on an archaeological
expedition in china
so what if finn fang fume not only
brings in the dragon element but also
happens to be the 10 rings
original alien owner seems like i'm
stretching
get those hammies loose remember those
toy leaks i mentioned earlier both the
funko pop and hasbro lines of toys
feature a dragon
oh come
the drawings have four fingers toys got
five
dude these toiley companies you know
matches something with the studio
with marvel especially favorites
like this now i look like there's a
godzilla
i like covering links to a different
degree where it's like
it's still in theory realm yeah you know
like but we don't know 100
yet you know we don't know 100 when you
do a toilet like
9 out of 10 times it's like pretty much
a confirmation
that's what it is damn those toy leagues
kick you
right in the ass don't they that's a
that's a real shame yeah it's gotta be a
way to guard against those spoilers
particularly
why how could
master matpat predicts the mandarin's
big bicep hugging 10 rings are actually
the fancy finger decor of fin fang
foom or some other giant dragon and that
using them will either summon control
defeat or maybe
free the mcu's first kaiju sized
sentient monster where the mandatory sky
beam is gonna mark the spot then again
it is all just a theory a film theory
and cut also subscribe to let me know
how wrong
i was when this movie eventually comes
out though gotta admit i'm feeling good
about this one
now you press subscribe button yet great
you're probably right
i would like fing fang fume or if
whatever reinvention they do of the
dragon and whatever
if if they call him think painful or not
i would want fing fang foom
to be like in the world to say the least
i don't want it to i want the dragon to
exist
i don't know about the dragon showing up
in this movie as like the big villain
in the third act for just the impression
i mean now you're already introducing
this
tournament of sorts or introduces his
character to this other world
and you gotta have it grounded in a
personal take between
i feel like between the mandarin and
shang chi
you gotta have that be the central focus
and you just have like some big dragon
coming at the end
or maybe if it's diluted throughout the
movie or if like the tree kind of like
the goro
like people are referencing mortal
kombat for this so maybe it's like the
goro
like the night the way the 95 version
use them i don't know i'm conflicted i
love the idea of fing fang foom
being in the world and being set up i
don't know about him showing up and like
you defeat the mandarin or the final
battle just the dragon shows up and i
don't know we gotta fight this dragon
now yeah
maybe if they did some kind of cut away
like you know
past lore sequence or some kind of
historical flashback or whatever to the
origins of the ten rings or something
and then maybe if they tease
the actual return of coming of finn fang
fume in this universe at the end or
something because
i keep having to remind myself this is
ostensibly like a fighting tournament
movie
yeah so like where would this character
fit
quite literally into that and also with
shanxi's powers and whatnot it seems
like it would also be kind of an odd he
seems like he would need a lot of backup
and shanxi has the ability to clone
himself and no one really touches on
that for some reason
um uh i was later introduced power but
that's just a thing
anyway guys thank you so much for being
here what did you think about this film
theory video
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least
buddy this should come as no surprise to
you who do you think i'm gonna shout out
i think it's going to be jt
that's right because you're the asian
one you're the asian one
the asian one you are our hawaiian
japanese best friend of patriots they're
not even japanese
and not even japanese maybe there's a
japanese guy in shanghai
well you know trevor slattery said the
thing about the fortune cookie recipe
being from japan so
there you go i miss you jt i miss idea
day i miss your warm calming presence
jt stands for japanese tits
yeah it's got great nips oh you should
see them we've gotten to see them a
couple times and i wish we could share
them here on this video but we don't
want to get restricted i've always said
japanese men have got the best nipples
and jt honest that greatest nipples
in all of the patreon wear that like a
badge of honor two badges a month
[Music]